[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend ihnen allen die Debatte um
Asyl und Migration nimmt in Deutschland
deutlich an Fahrt auf das ist am
Wochenende schon deshalb zu spüren weil
sich die Politiker Interviews in den
Zeitungen um kaum etwas anderes drehen
die Parteien haben das Thema
identifiziert mit dem sich Wahlen
gewinnen lassen aber eben auch verloren
gehen können
Oppositionschef Friedrich Merz ist heute
bei Parteifreunden in Sachsen-Anhalt und
holt sich dort Rückendeckung nach seinem
Zahnersatz aus dieser Woche und nachdem
vom sozialflügel seiner eigenen CDU
folgende Bemerkung kam viele Mitglieder
schämten sich für ihren
Parteivorsitzenden Andreas Weise jetzt
mit mir
es ist ein Heimspiel für Friedrich
Merzien Magdeburg seit seiner Rückkehr
in die Politik ist er der Favorit der
CDU Sachsen-Anhalt und so geht er sich
nicht gut gelaunt durch die Reihen der
klatschenden Landesparteitags
Delegierten in seiner Rede dauert es ca
20 Minuten bis er eher beiläufig auf die
umstrittenen zahnarztäußerungen
anlässlich der Migrationsdebatte eingeht
kenne mich dazu zu diesem Thema auch mal
kritisch etwas zu sagen da muss nicht
gleich die ganze Republik in
Schnappatmung verfallen wenn man mal zu
diesem Themen etwas klar und deutlich
sagt
sachsen-anhaltsministerpräsident
Haseloff springt in seiner Rede märz zur
Seite das sage ich exemplarisch nur
deswegen auch weil es darum geht dass
wir als Union für uns auch in Anspruch
nehmen dass wir eine bürgerliche Partei
der Mitte sind eine hohe politische
kulturpflegen und demzufolge wenn wir
etwas sagen es für unser Land und für
unsere Demokratie machen und nicht für
irgend welche populistischen Dinge doch
in anderen Teilen der Partei lösen März
wiederholte verbale Attacken Entsetzen
aus er soll seine Äußerungen
zurücknehmen oder auf die
Kanzlerkandidatur verzichten so eine
Forderung von heute mit so einer Aussage
kann man politisch nicht in ein
Wahlkampf gehen man hilft auch
denjenigen die gerade weil kämpfen
stehen die Parteitags Delegierten in
Magdeburg stehen dagegen klar hinter
März auch wenn nicht alle mit seiner
Wortwahl glücklich sind
dass das vielleicht überzogen worden mit
dem Zahnärzten okay aber das Thema in
sich ist doch das Problem was wir haben
in Deutschland darüber müssen wir reden
weil die Leute verstehen nicht mehr
wieso sie arbeiten gehen und die
Sozialleistungen für andere immer
steigen man hätte das vielleicht etwas
diplomatischer ausdrucken können mehr
bezogen auf das Gesundheitssystem
allgemein in Deutschland und nicht sagen
wir mal fokussiert auf ja die
Problematiken die uns jetzt aus dem
politischer politisch bedrängen aber
trotzdem ist er noch für Sie der
richtige Bundesvorsitzende ja er ist
immer noch der richtige
Bundesvorsitzende für mich ja und so gab
der Parteichef den Parteifreunden mit
Blick auf die Wahlen in drei
ostdeutschen Bundesländern im kommenden
Jahr noch eine klare Botschaft mit auf
den Weg
ausgeschlossen es wird keine zusammen
arbeiten dass wir mal sehr klar und
deutlich zu sagen es wird keine
Zusammenarbeit mit dieser Partei geben
und es ist möglich mit anderen aber wir
müssen so stark werden dass ich andere
nach uns richten und nicht wir nach
anderen drei Stunden Wohlfühlprogramm
für Friedrich Merz in Sachsen-Anhalt
doch die Debatten um den rechten Ton
werden so schnell nicht aufhören
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz wird heute so
zitiert die Zahl der Flüchtlinge die
nach Deutschland Streben ist im Moment
zu hoch das ist ein anderer Tonfall als
vom Kanzler in der Vergangenheit zu
hören war und auch ein deutlicher
Unterschied zum wir schaffen das seiner
Vorgängerin im Amt Andrea Maurer ist für
uns in Berlin genannt Andrea steuert
dieses Land da jetzt gerade quer durch
die Bank auf einen grundsätzlich neuen
und schärferen Asyl Kurs zu
nun zumindest lässt sich da eine gewisse
Dynamik schon beobachten die ja heute
auch in den kanzlerworten Ausdruck
fahren zum einen ist diese Dynamik
sicher den Landtagswahlen in Hessen und
Bayern geschuldet zum anderen ist die
Überforderung für Städte Kommunen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gerade so real
dass uns die Debatten um Begrenzung von
Migration und bessere Integration sicher
auch nach den Wahlen weiter begleiten
werden und politischen Handlungsdruck
erzeugen könnten etwa die Frage ob
Geldleistung für geflüchtete in
Sachleistung umgewandelt werden also
beispielsweise Bezahlkarten mit den
geflüchtete dann im Einzelhandel waren
das täglichen Bedarfs kaufen sollen was
ja der FDP Minister Volker Wissing
fordert mit der Begründung Geld sei ein
Zitat Anreiz zur Einreise ins
Sozialsystem das ist diese Bezahlkarten
er tatsächlich für die Bundesländer
schon als Optionen gibt und nur seit sie
nur selten genutzt werden ganz einfach
weil der Verwaltungsaufwand zu groß ist
das gehört zur Wahrheit in dieser doch
sehr plakativ geführten Debatte dazu
also ein verschärfter Ton ja und
womöglich auch ein verschärfter asylkurs
viele Debattenbeiträge heute und in den
letzten Tagen aber wie geht es denn
jetzt ganz konkret weiter erstmal du
hast es schon angesprochen sind ja
Landtagswahlen nächsten Sonntag die
werden nämlich an noch abgewartet und
dann ja also Oppositionsführer Friedrich
Merz hat den Kanzler heute ja zu einem
migrationsgespräch aufgefordert und da
höre ich aus dem Kanzleramt der Kanzler
ist immer zum Gespräch bereit allerdings
nicht als Showdown oder Gipfel und man
verweist gerne darauf dass Friedrich
Merz vor allem mit medialen Forderungen
präsent sei während der Kanzler mit den
unionsgeführten Ländern ja tatsächlich
schon verhandelt denn da steht dann der
große migrationsgipfel im November an
erst im November muss man sagen aus
Sicht der Dynamik dieser Debatten über
die wir gerade gesprochen haben
erscheint das äh ziemlich spät und im
Hinblick auf die Frage wie Kommunen
besser unterstützt werden können hat
Kanzler Scholz daher heute schon ein
Vorschlag in Richtung November gemacht
er hat sich für offen gezeigt für eine
pro Kopfpauschale die die Länder für
Versorgung und Integration ja schon
lange fordern also dass ein konkretes
kanzlersignal hinein in den fernen
November Andrea vielen Dank für diese
Informationen live aus Berlin und dann
gucken wir jetzt auf die Situation
direkt vor Ort und zwar heute in die
Hansestadt Greifswald in Vorpommern eine
Uni statt mit grünem Oberbürgermeister
und gleichzeitig eine Stadt in der sich
die Stimmung dreht wenn es um den Zug
von geflüchteten geht Susanne
Nena und Leonie sind
kindergartenfreundinnen beide hören
gerne Geschichten
heute lesen ihn Mütter aus verschiedenen
Kulturen vor dann wird übersetzt für
manche ist das Gesagte vertraut für
manche neu das ist ganz wichtig dass die
Kinder auch in ihrer Muttersprache
Berücksichtigung finden damit sie sich
willkommen fühlen angenommen fühlen
lernen können in der Universitätsstadt
Greifswald engagieren sich viele Haupt-
und Ehrenamtliche für geflüchtete
neuneinhalb Prozent der Bevölkerung ist
aus anderen Ländern zugewandert im
Sommer gab es einen Bürgerentscheid zwei
Drittel der Wähler stimmten dagegen dass
auf städtischen Grund wie zum Beispiel
auf diesem alten Sportplatz Container
für Flüchtlinge entstehen
obwohl es eigentlich um die Art der
Unterbringung von geflüchteten ging
nutzten viele ihre Stimme als Zeichen
gegen Zuwanderung ich denke dass die
Kapazitäten ausgeschöpft sind in
Deutschland insgesamt an seine Grenzen
kommt und die Problematik ist auch dabei
die dementsprechend unterzubringen nicht
nur sie zu versorgen dass sie sich auch
ein bisschen und sie deutschen
bürgerlichen Dinge aneignen das ist
leider zu viel jetzt das können wir
nicht mehr Stimmen alles ich bin
bestimmt
Menschenfreund aber jetzt irgendwann ist
gut
Oberbürgermeister Stefan Fassbinder muss
jetzt nach dem Bürgerentscheid nach
anderen Unterkünften für die ihm
zugewiesenen geflüchteten suchen zum
Beispiel in diesen Wohnungen er will
hineinsager des Bürgerentscheids
überzeugen das Migration beim
Fachkräftemangel helfen kann
es wird immer Menschen geben die strikt
dagegen sind dass Menschen aus fremden
Ländern zu uns kommen das ist
kurzsichtig und es ist auch nicht
humanitär aber ich denke viele Menschen
können wir wieder gewinnen wenn wir
diesen Schritt hinkriegen von der
illegalen Einwanderung die wir zum
größten teil haben zu einer geregelten
legalen Einwanderung die wir dringend
benötigen das müssen wir aber schaffen
das können wir aber nicht vor Ort
leisten das ist eine Sache der
Bundesregierung
die Aktiven vom Kulturzentrum stratze
hatten sich beim Bürgerentscheid für die
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte eingesetzt in
Projekten arbeiten sie mit Migranten um
sie zu integrieren das nein beim
Bürgervotum deuten sie als Zeichen
zunehmende Misstrauens gegenüber Fremden
ich meine uns hat es als Gruppe noch mal
zusammengeschweißt und hat motiviert
durch das Negative
weiterzumachen hat die Bedeutung davon
gezeigt und
zumindest wissen wir jetzt wie die Lage
ist
die Stimmung in Greifswald bleibt nach
dem Bürgerentscheid angespannt das
Problem der flüchtlingsunterbringung hat
er nicht gelöst
aber interessant was da ein grüner
Oberbürgermeister sagt so jetzt
Nachrichten im Überblick Hannah du
beginnst mit ersten Trends einer Wahl
die durchaus Folgen für ganz Europa
haben könnte so ist es
die Wahlberechtigten in der Slowakei
haben heute ein neues Parlament gewählt
seit 22 Uhr sind die Wahllokale
geschlossen erste Prognosen deuten auf
einen Kopf an Kopf Rennen zwischen der
links-national ins Meer und der
liberalen Partei progressives Slowakei
hin die offenbar leicht vorne liegt ein
Endergebnis wird morgen erwartet sollte
dies mehr die Wahl gewinnen dürfte dies
auch für die Ukraine deutlicher
Auswirkungen haben die Partei hatte im
Falle eines Sieges den Stopp von
Waffenlieferungen angekündigt
die Bundesregierung hat Serbien dazu
aufgerufen unverzüglich seine Truppen an
der Grenze zum Kosovo zu reduzieren
zuvor hatten bereits die USA einen Abzug
gefordert und sich besorgt über einen
großen Militär Aufmarsch an der Grenze
gezeigt der beispiellos sei wegen der
jüngste aufgeflammten Spannungen hatte
erst gestern die NATO angekündigt ihre
Präsenz im Kosovo zu verstärken der
Kosovo hatte sich 2008 für unabhängig
erklärt Serbien erkennt das aber nicht
an
das US-Repräsentantenhaus hat für einen
übergangshaushalt gestimmt um die
drohende Haushaltssperre in den
Vereinigten Staaten abzuwenden damit ist
eine erste Hürde genommen jetzt muss
noch der Senat zustimmen ansonsten tritt
um Mitternacht Ortszeit der sogenannte
shutdown in Kraft die Zustimmung gilt
allerdings als wahrscheinlich im Senat
halten die Demokraten die Mehrheit der
übergangshaushalt gilt für 45 Tage Hilfe
für die Ukraine ist darin nicht
vorgesehen den Gesetzentwurf hatte der
Vorsitzende des
US-Repräsentantenhauses heute vorgelegt
und klar war jedoch ob seine
zerstrittenen Republikaner ihn überhaupt
unterstützen würden
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag
lauten 1 17 20 36 42 45 Superzahl 0 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
der oktober startet teils mit sommerlich
warmen Temperaturen die Wetteraussichten
morgen im Norden und Osten viele Wolken
und vor allem in Küsten Nähe zeitweise
Regen sonst meist sonnig oder nur locker
bewölkt 17 bis 26 Grad am Montag ganz im
Norden Regen sonst viel Sonne und mit 19
bis 30 Grad ungewöhnlich warm am
Dienstag aufkommende Schauer und
Gewitter am Mittwoch wechselhaft und
deutlich kühler
das helle Licht bei der Nacht gibt Halt
und Hoffnung für die Arbeit unter Tage
ein Lied verbindet Bergbauregionen in
Ost- und West es ist eine Hymne von
Schalke 04 und vom FC Erzgebirge Aue es
gibt unzählige Versionen grubenchor
classic Pop und sogar Hip Hop aber die
Wurzeln liegen im Erzgebirge
nachgewiesenermaßen haben sie es etwa in
Schneeberg in Sachsen bereits
1678 gesungen und jetzt ist es auch noch
in materielles Kulturerbe der UNESCO
Stefan Kirch
[Musik]
es ist uralt und doch hunderttausendfach
geklickt in den sozialen Netzwerken die
Videokampagne so geht sächsisch hat mit
Interpretationen des steigerliedes
offenbar einen Nerv getroffen jeder
kennt es man singt es in Stadien bei
Paraden und natürlich im Bergwerk selbst
für die Fünftklässler des Altenberger
Gymnasiums hat es eine ganz besondere
Bedeutung das Steigerlied ist ihre
schulhymne
[Musik]
schon angez
ündet so viele erfahren auch das erste
mal etwas über diese schwere Arbeit über
die Rolle des Bergbaus der letztendlich
zur Besiedlung unserer Region unsere
Heimat beigetragen hat der die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung ja
vorangetrieben hat wenn Heino Neuber
über das Steigerlied reden will wirft er
sich in Bergmanns habit er ist Hüter des
Wissens über das Lied hat ein Buch über
seine Geschichte geschrieben und weiß
also genau warum es so viele mögen ich
denke schon dass dieses Lied ein Stück
Heimat ist und da an der Stelle sicher
den Heimat Begriffen nicht als eine
Verortung an einen bestimmten Platz oder
in einem bestimmte Stadt oder in
Bergbaugebiet verstanden sondern
wirklich auch so diese innere Heimat die
ja im Herzen zu Hause ist das Singen des
steigerliedes wird inzwischen von der
UNESCO zum immateriellen Kulturerbe
gerechnet gesungen wird die Hymne der
Bergleute nicht nur auf der Zeichen
Bühne sondern auch von massenchor auf
Schalke
das liegt eben auch daran dass man das
Lied also etwas einigen des erkannt hat
als etwas auch was ohne große Umschweife
zu brauchen oder ohne eine tiefgründige
Erklärung oder mit irgendwelchen
Hintergründen mit denen man sich
auseinandersetzen muss was man mitnehmen
kann
mitgenommen hat es aktuell die
breakdance-gruppe sechstens die Wagen
sich ans neueste Video und damit an die
wohl erste getanzte Version des
steigerliedes für den Chef der halb
amerikanischen Fidler Band trouble Notes
eine neue Erfahrung die Melodie hat
etwas speziell ich habe gesagt dass
vielleicht der Steigerlied ist der erste
Box Lied vom sexen das kann sein und
genau es ist ja es ist von den Melodie
es ist schön und es ist wie ein Ohrwurm
ne
ein Ohrwurm der diesmal ganz ohne Text
funktionieren muss aber den singt ja
ohnehin jeder im Geiste mit
[Musik]
bis morgen und Glückauf wir wünschen
Ihnen noch einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]